SHIGERU MIYAGAWA:
Guest lecturers
are an important part
of "Visualizing Japan,"
the residential course.
Each time I teach it, I
have Professor John Dower
guest lecture at least
once, sometimes twice.
So I also invite
Dr. Ellen Sebring,
who is a specialist on
visual culture and history.
And to prepare for
these lecturers,
I ask the guest lecturers
to give me some assignment
to give the students.
In the case of
Professor John Dower,
he gave me a series of questions
about the MOOC content.
What did they think about this?
What do they think about this?
How do they improve the MOOC?
And the students wrote a
single page single spaced.
And I gave that to Professor
Dower ahead of time.
And he read it.
And I think he spent almost
half the class talking
about what the students wrote.
These students are very,
very engaged with the class.